Đi thà nội, mỗi dì vụ chỗ át gòn, không sát đẹp, mà lại thật anh tình thì đi đâu.
Gấm buốt nhất ở đây chúng ta thôi, nhìn chỉ cần bước trên qua cạnh cử,
và sẽ thấy như mình vừa là bởi hôm xa thòn tất khác.
Nó là vị lai, đây là một trong những hàng trái nổi tiếng mật tiếp tủ đô.
Ở đây không xa không chỉ để gặp, mà là để hí tờ,
thì nước trời, những tàn kây xanh mất, tất cả dưới đàn số dành,
giúp chúng ta gòn lại hết những mệt mọi ngoài kia, để tình kể sự ăn in trong chính miền.
Mọi trời ở đây không phải tất đẹp như mọi người vẫn nghĩ đâu,
tất nhiên mọi át gần nối, để không bị ôi hẹt dài,
bối để tức ăn đưa lên bàn, nhiều đều trong chút thì một tắc phần nghệ phật.
Thì một tế cũng lưới, là con người ở đây,
tử lưới bàn tay, tay hoa, có các nâu bếp, luôn tìm bị chọn thức khâu chỉ biến,
cho đến sự đàn tiếp mài bàn, chứ như cử đưa mũ như sự.
Tất cả họ để làm việc bằng sự tất tâm, để đặc bảo và có một trái nghiệp chọn về và thứ thái nhất.
Vị lai không chỉ là một điểm dưới chân để ăn ngon,
đây là ní bệnh đạc lại nước, và khơi tạo những nghiệm vui hẹn dàng.
Nếu có gì kể thăm hà nội, lừng quên xanh cho mình vụ vui chưa thích bánh lọc tại đây.